are you doing today sir I'm good brother
I want to start by saying congrats on
the movie
thank you brother I have so many things
to talk about and I can't talk about
half of them but I want to know though
you're making them breakable back way
back when how much did you know about
the ending of this movie back then and
how much did it change as a result of
the years and split well the wonderful
side effect of taking so long
is that I could bring nostalgia into it
and I could use footage from unbreakable
and really talk about this idea of what
if you thought you were a superhero for
your entire life your entire generation
what is it what how does that wear on
you how does that did it is it truthful
or do you start to doubt yourself and
how does it affect your loved ones I
could talk about all of those things in
glass which I didn't get a chance to and
also with the explosion of the comic
book culture I could reference that in
the movie which I really couldn't know
if I'd done it like sequentially right
after unbreakable cuz I'm breakable
would have been the initial movement in
that in that in that conversation about
comic books sure but my my specific
thing yes the third act of this movie
was saying that specifically yes I'm
come just curious I had a question in my
folder the folder that had all the notes
and it's a quite I'm trying to see how
to how to say it without saying anything
the question was how come no one knows
that there are superheroes that was the
question in in the folder and there's an
answer to that sure I it's just so
interesting and during the writing
process for this how much are you
writing a treatment of the whole movie
and how much are you sort of just
exploring on your own like where the
script goes and then and that dictates
maybe some ideas I I work in this
fashion I go I write for a screenplay
and in the glass was exactly the same
way I write a note full notebook full of
ideas random ideas and they can be
contradictory main character does this
main character falls in love or whatever
it is and there contradict no main care
doesn't want to love and whatever sticks
at the end and once the notebook is full
when I
feel like it's full I go to outline form
and then the outline form is where it's
won or lost because movies are structure
and that's where it's lost and I spend
six weeks there figuring out the issues
of where this is the movement they get
to the hospital this is what happens it
becomes about the family members and
then they come in here and then this is
what happens and this is when they
escape and why and the ticking clock is
once that starts just all the way to
then and you work out the structure in
those six weeks and then the final thing
is writing the screenplay which takes
about four or five months to do and all
the details that go into there but you
got to be careful that you got the
structure right before you go to that
face because you can fall in love with
your execution completely the editing
room is ultimately the final rewrite I'm
very curious how the structure of the
film possibly changed result of the edit
and also deleted scenes the a lot tons
of deleted scenes I think in retrospect
what ended up happening was this was my
longest screenplay and my longest first
cut by a lot when you say how long was
your first cut 3 2003 30 no is that like
an assembly where it's everything or so
it's everything it's everything that we
shot but edited it's edited Internet and
so it's there it's the screenplay in in
that form 2-year point of the last draft
being editorial and I think in
retrospect the fruit this was the first
time I was writing characters that I
already knew so I could write a lot and
that's not normal normally I'm finding
them as I'm writing so just as I find
them I finish and that that wasn't the
case here I knew them beforehand so it
was much longer I could write more and
the editing process was what is the most
in the essence of what I needed so
there's a lot of deleted scenes for the
blu-ray and all that stuff I have so
many more questions I'm already out of
time I gotta go but but